matthieu pigasse bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes avec c'est
parce que vous venez d'écrire un livre
le monde d'après le monde d'après la
crise à l'étude avant que vous l'avez
écrit avec gilles finchelstein qui est
directeur de la fondation jean jaurès la
fondation jean jaurès est ce qu'on
appelle un think tank c'est à dire un
organisme de penser leur injection et de
réflexion proche du parti socialiste
donc pour vous situez vous votre origine
c'est la fonction publique
le cabinet notamment de dominique
strauss-kahn dont vous êtes restés
proches et vous êtes maintenant banquier
d'affaires et pas n'importe quel
banquier d'affaires puisque vous êtes
vice président europe de la banque
lazard donc un petit mot d'explication
sur comment on est banquier d'affaires
dans la tourmente la plus la plus
violente que le monde financier est
connu depuis on laissera les
statisticiens ensuite dia depuis combien
de temps
d'abord j'ai passé plus de temps dans la
fonction publique au ministère des
finances que chez lazard j'ai passé huit
ans au ministère des finances
93 eur 4 en près de deux minutes deux
ministres pardon dominique strauss kahn
et laurent fabius puis effectivement
cinq ans désormais à la banque lazard
alors je ne suis pas ce que l'on appelle
un banquier d'affaires un mot peut-être
d'explications sur ce qu'est mon métier
oui je suis pas banquier commercial ça
signifie que lazard n'est pas une banque
qui fait des opérations financières qui
prête ou qui fait du financement
nous ne sommes pas banquier d'affaires
mais je ne suis pas banquier d'affaires
je ne fais pas d'affaires moi même je
suis ce que l'on appelle un banquier
conseil c'est à dire que j'accompagne
les entreprises qui sont nos partenaires
dans la définition et la mise en place
de leur stratégie stratégie
principalement des grands groupes
d'ailleurs nombre des grands groupes
bien sûr du cac 40 ou des entreprises de
taille plus modeste petites et moyennes
alors que banquiers et de gauche
ce qui est aussi une peut-être une
difficulté supplémentaire
non c'est pas une difficulté on peut
tout à fait défendre des idées qui ne
sont pas celles de ses intérêts et au
fond c'est ça pour moi la définition
d'un banquet de gauche c'est possible
alors l'intérêt de votre livre c'est que
ça s'appelle le monde d'après donc on a
d'ailleurs de savoir comment
va atterrir au comptant après après la
sortie mais auparavant peut-être un mot
parce que se livrent aussi explique la
crise donne une lecture de la crise avec
une originalité qui vous est propre qui
est que vous expliquez que la crise
financière
celles qui mettent en péril l'ensemble
du système bancaire n'est pas la cause
de la crise économique celle dans
laquelle nous sommes entrés avec
l'augmentation phénoménale du chômage
massif dans certains pays moindre mais
néanmoins très spectaculaire et
douloureuse chez nous et vous expliquer
qu'au contraire la crise économique
au fond précédé cette crise financière
alors comment l'expliquez-vous parce que
dans la lecture pure et simple des
événements dans leur déroulement
on a eu quand même droit à la crise des
subprimes depuis la faillite de
certaines banques d'affaires puis
l'ébranlement du système bancaire
lui-même avant d'en arriver à la réalité
économique d'aujourd'hui donc le déroulé
des événements fait qu'on comprend pas
oui alors tout de suite votre thèse un
mot d'explication ceci vous avez très
bien résumé ce qui est une des thèses de
livres effectivement la crise financière
n'est pas effectivement la cause de la
crise économique
elle en est une manifestation un
symptôme un peu comme la fièvre et et
cache quelque chose de plus profond
au fond ce que nous disons c'est que
depuis une dizaine d'années en europe
comme surtout aux états unis
les fondamentaux économiques étaient
médiocres
disons le différemment était moyen il y
avait de faibles gains de productivité
un faible effort d'investissement et
tout ça s'est traduit par une faible
croissance des revenus est est ce que
les états ont cherché à faire les
politiques publiques ont cherché à faire
c'est à compenser cette faiblesse de la
croissance à compenser cette faiblesse
de la progression des revenus et des
salaires par l'endettement et c'est ça
qui a provoqué si vous voulez de la
formation de bulles spéculatives tout au
long des dix dernières années qui ont
fini par exploser dans la crise des
subprimes c'est à dire au fond ça c'est
vu aux etats-unis une politique celle de
bush notamment favorable aux très peu
qui sont très très riches et la classe
moyenne
le membre idée mais pour maintenir le
niveau de vie en quelque sorte de cette
classe moyenne dont les revenus souvent
b c'est absolument pour maintenir leur
niveau de vie
endettement c'est en nettement cumulatif
est finalement collapse et c'est
exactement ça c'est à dire qu'aux états
unis on a observé un double phénomène
depuis 10 15 ans comme je les dis
d'abord très faible progression des
revenus sur les dix dernières années
parfois même si sur certaines années
recul des revenus est par ailleurs et
parallèlement d'ailleurs accroissement
des inégalités et donc les politiques
publiques américaines monétaire et plus
largement d'ailleurs budgétaires et
fiscales ont cherché à compenser cet
effet par un surcroît d'endettement et
c'est cette bulle d'endettement qui a
fini par exploser
alors comment en sortir comment en
sortir tout le monde regarde là où est
née la crise aux etats unis tout le
monde regarde le plan obama déjà
d'ailleurs critiqué à peine sortie vous
me direz c'est la règle démocratique
enfin c'est assez tout de suite
la critique est assez vif comment vous
même appréciez vous ce plan obama est ce
qu'il nous donne une chance de sortie
plus ou moins rapide de la crise
comment en sortir je désire le plus
rapidement possible c'est l'urgence
aujourd'hui c'est de rester vivant il y
a des réponses de moyen terme qui va
falloir mettre en oeuvre par exemple
plus de réglementations plus de
régulation mais ce qu'il faut faire
aujourd'hui à court terme c'est réparer
le moteur qui s'est cassé et qui est le
moteur de la consommation
revenons sur ce qu'on a dit il ya un
instant le moteur de la croissance
américaine est d'ailleurs la croissance
mondiale c'était le consommateur
américain qui a pu s'endetter ce faisant
il a consommé il a importé du reste du
monde vers les états unis
et il a fait tourner nos usines
simplement il ya eu un excès
d'endettement qui fait que la crise a
éclaté le le résultat de ça c'est ce
qu'on appelle la disparition du
consommateur américain c'est à dire que
il y a un effet un manque à gagner en
termes de croissance que l'on peut
chiffrer à 1500 milliards de dollars
c'est un peu comme le moteur d'un avion
qui tout d'un coup aurait arrêté de
tourner donc l'urgence c'est de remettre
en marche ce moteur comment fait-on et
bien c'est les plans de relance et de ce
point de vue là le plan de relance du
président obama est une très bonne chose
par son ampleur à peu près 800 milliards
de dollars alors évidemment c'est pas ça
qui va compenser la totalité du
gagner mais il faut également que les
européens fassent l'autre moitié du
chemin
et puis par c'est une bonne chose donc
par son ampleur et puis par les mesures
mises en oeuvre qui touche à la fois
l'investissement et à la fois la
consommation
alors ce mélange investissement
consommation est évidemment au coeur de
tous les débats
on a presque d'ailleurs l'impression
petite parenthèse que la droite dit
investissement la gauche dit
consommation est-ce qu'il peut y avoir
une sortie de crise de droite
une sortie de crise de gauche ou est ce
que mes fils eyadema mans le money qui
libre et très certainement au milieu
c'est à dire que moi je crois qu'il faut
agir sur ces deux piliers d'un côté
l'investissement et de l'autre la
consommation il faut pas agir que sur
l'investissement il ne faut pas agir que
sur la consommation je les dis
aujourd'hui le facteur premier de la
crise c'est l'effondrement de la demande
intérieure l'effondrement de la
consommation
on le voit d'ailleurs sur ce qu'on
appelle les biens durables alors le
meilleur exemple c'est l'automobile les
suit les ventes d'automobiles aux
etats-unis ont chuté sur le seul mois de
janvier de plus de 50% en france elles
ont chuté de 20%
donc on voit bien l'effondrement de la
demande et de la consommation il faut
impérativement agir là dessus il faut la
soutenir
de la même façon qu'il faut évidemment
préparer l'avenir et donc mettre en
place des plans d'infrastructures c'est
à dire jouer sur l'investissement mais
alors pour venir à la france et à
l'europe est ce que ce qui est vrai de
l'automobile est vrai d autres secteurs
est ce que vraiment on a un effondrement
de la consommation en europe qui
justifierait une forte relance par la
consommation comme aux états unis
première question et d'autre part est ce
qu'il est vraiment raisonnable de penser
qu'une relance par la consommation dans
la france seule ne peut être efficace
est-ce que de façon évidente la toute
relance par la consommation ne passe pas
par une mise en mouvement de tous les
pays européens
en même temps si tout le monde relance
en même temps la consommation en effet
si la france le fait seul comment vous
situez vous le rappelle c'est de ces
deux problèmes vous avez posé plusieurs
questions donc
plusieurs réponses la première il est
vrai que les pays européens ne sont pas
touchées de la même façon au même moment
les premiers pays qui ont été touchés et
qui d'ailleurs avait mis en place des
politiques publiques tout à fait
comparable à celle des états unis c'est
l'angleterre et l'espagne excès
d'endettement puis effondrement de la
consommation
c'est la raison pour laquelle les
anglais ont très vite d'ailleurs joué
cherché à relancer la consommation en
baissant la tva la france et l'allemagne
ou moins connus des excès d'endettement
donc l'impact aujourd'hui sur la
consommation est plus faible
ceci dit je crois qu'il ne faut pas se
tromper la crise ne va pas contourner
nos frontières comme le nuage de
tchernobyl c'est à dire qu'à un moment
ou un autre
et d'ailleurs on commence à le voir dans
les chiffres chute de la production
industrielle montée du chômage baisse de
la posture est impressionnante elle est
très impressionnant nous nous allons
être touchées mais pour vivre d'un mot
sur l'endettement la france est de
notoriété publique de tout temps
d'ailleurs un pays qui épargnent et qui
parle beaucoup alors qu'aux etats-unis
non les jours il en soit il s'adresse
est exact oui non mais c'est tout à fait
exact 1 en france la grande différence
entre la france les états unis
l'angleterre ou l'espagne c'est
effectivement un taux d'épargné privée
plus important donc une consommation
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui qui résistent
mieux ceci dit est ce que ce que je
voulais dire c'est évidemment que nous
allons être rattrapé c'est à dire que
par la crise et on le voit dans les
chiffres d'un prévisions de croissance
on ne va pas rester à l'écart du
mouvement
donc il faut agir il faut agir le plus
vite possible je crois qu'il faut
vraiment prendre la crise à la gorge
avant qu'elle ne s'installe
mais là vous avez parfaitement raison
c'est que on est dans une crise globale
donc la réponse doit être globale toute
relance n'a de sens que si elle est
concertée entre les différents pays de
l'union européenne et otan je crois les
pouvoirs publics européens
sous l'impulsion du président sarkozy
ont très bien joué en matière de plan
bancaire
le plan de sauvetage bancaire a permis
d'éviter le drame avant en octobre
autant en matière de relance je crois
qu'il faut maintenant et de manière
urgente coordonner nos efforts ce qui
n'est pas le cas et parce qu'on voit que
chacun est un peu en ordre dispersé on a
vu l'allemagne tardé à se mettre en
mouvement mais reprendre de l'avancé par
rapport à nous et aujourd'hui le plan
français paraît un petit peu faibles ou
en tout cas statique un peu comme si au
fond on attendait des autres
notre notre sol évidemment ce n'est pas
une course 1 l'important c'est de partir
ensemble et d'arrivée on sent mais c'est
vrai que là où on jugeait où on pouvait
juger que la france était plutôt en
avance dans les réponses qu'elle
apportait je les dis en matière bancaire
ou en matière budgétaire
on peut constater aujourd'hui qu'elle a
pris un peu de retard donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle je crois il faut
très vite ajuster le plan tel qu'il a
été annoncé par le président sarkozy
petit exercice de politique fiction vous
avez une entrée difficile oui vous avez
été donc collaborateur de dominique
strauss kahn de laurent fabius à bercy
vous vous retrouvez aujourd'hui dans la
même situation imaginons que dominique
strauss kahn au lieu d'être au fmi on
veut dire à manduel familles se
retrouvent convoqué à bercy
vous lui conseillez quoi qui soit
différent au fond de ce que l'on a de ce
que ce à quoi on a droit aujourd'hui est
ce que est ce que l'effort doit
prioritairement absolument porter au
niveau européen
qu'est-ce qu'est ce que vous lui dites
fiction l'arrêté visite seuil de route
voulu d'assurer une petite fiction c'est
toujours très facile lorsqu'on n'est pas
aux responsabilités et qu'on n'a pas de
contrainte particulière
enfin c'est aussi l'intérêt de faire la
politique fiction moi je crois
profondément ce que je vous ai dit c'est
à dire que je lui dirai il faut agir à
court terme et de manière coordonnée
notamment avec les allemands a géré à
court terme c'est compenser
l'effondrement de la demande et par
exemple pourquoi pas jouer sur la télé à
réduire la tva pour essayer de rebooster
la consommation très vite
les anglais l'ont fait alors j'entends
bien que on conteste on s'interroge sur
l'efficacité de la baisse de la tva
anglaise moi je dit deux choses 1 c'est
trop tôt pour juger me semble-t-il est
en tout état de cause que se serait-il
passé en grande bretagne s'il ne l'avait
pas fait bon donc moi je lui dirai
jouons sur le sueur sur la tva pour
essayer de soutenir la consommation le
plus vite et plus fort possible
et puis surtout rapprochons-nous des
allemands le moteur de l'europe
c'est historiquement le couple franco
allemand or au mieux il ronronne au pire
il a quelques ratés donc je crois qu'il
faut aujourd'hui travailler à nouveau
ensemble qu'ils en oublient qu'on est
dans un degré d'interdépendance france
et allemagne absolument fondamental
d'énormes effets si on si chacun joue
dans son coin c'est d'ailleurs la vente
de son la crise jean marie colombani
silo motorisé s'est pas seulement
l'interdépendance entre la france et
l'allemagne c'est l'interdépendance
globale assez la mondialisation c'est
véritablement la première crise mondiale
il ya des pays qui pensait pouvoir être
épargnée par la crise qui sont des
relais pays émergents l'inde la chine
vous interrogiez les dirigeants chinois
il ya quelques mois en septembre octobre
ils vous disaient non mais vous vous
êtes touchés par la crise financière
vous avez commis les excès vous allez
subir ou est puni d'une certaine façon
mais ces pays ont tous été rattrapé par
le par ce qui se passe donc je crois qu
une des grandes leçons de la crise c'est
vraiment ça c'est la mondialisation et
la globalisation
quel est votre j'allais dire par rapport
à tout cela votre niveau d'inquiétude
parce que en effet vous ne citiez la
chine on voit des cohortes gigantesque
de nouveaux chômeurs ont dit qu'en chine
à peu près l'équivalent de la population
active française va se retrouver au
chômage c'est à dire entre 25 et 30
millions de personnes c'est considérable
donc on se dit qu'on est peut-être en
effet au seuil de bouleversements et de
désordre très grave comment vous même
avez vous oui je crois qu'il ya
évidemment dans les pays émergents et
notamment particulièrement en chine je
crois plus qu'ailleurs des risques
sociaux et donc probablement politique
est liée à l'effondrement de la
croissance
bon ceci étant dit une des thèses du
livre une des autres thèse du livre
c'est le nouvel équilibre mondial c'est
à dire que nous sommes convaincus avec
gilles finchelstein mon co auteur et que
les pays émergents vont plus et mieux
résister ou vont repartir plus vite que
les beady émerger nous sommes convaincus
qu'au fond les pays émergents la chine
l'inde le brésil la russie ou
aujourd'hui toutes les rentes à leur
disposition à rentrer du travail
abondant et pas cher 30 du capital et
ses rangs des matières premières
absolument bien sûr rendu capital grâce
à l'accumulation des réserves de change
est de plus en plus d'ailleurs rente
technologiques liés à l'innovation qui
n'est plus notre notre notre seul atout
fincke et qui est de plus en plus
partagé donc je suis assez convaincu qu
effectivement les pays émergents vont
rencontrer des difficultés profondes
mais qu'elles seront transitoire et qu
ils rebondiront
vite que nous d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'il
faut souhaiter parce que c'est aussi par
là que se passera la sortie de crise et
vous restez pour nous mêmes donc y
sommes quand même dans une situation
sans matières premières avec des
difficultés qui dont on voit quelle
qu'elle s'aggrave
oui alors bon d'abord il faut pas tenir
des discours enfin moi je pense qu'il
faut toujours résisté aux critiques ou
discours du pire bon je pense néanmoins
qu'on traverse une crise très profonde
sans précédent c'est d'ailleurs le seul
titre de vue il faut rappeler c'est la
première fois depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale c'est à dire en réalité c'est
la première fois depuis la grande crise
de 29 que le pic mondial c'est à dire la
croissance mondiale est en récession
bon moi je les dis je pense qu'en fait
cette crise elle était en germe depuis
dix ans nous sommes confrontés à des
difficultés majeures faible vitalité
démographique mais même si la france se
comporte mieux que les autres je les dis
faibles investissements faible gain de
productivité pour autant nous avons des
atouts il va falloir jouer avec ses
atouts c'est une capacité d'innovation
et je crois pour les etats-unis une
capacité de rebond est très importante
on va vous laisser sur ce mot
relativement optimiste matthieu pigasse
donc c'est ce livre s'appelle le monde
d'après une crise sans précédent ce sont
aussi des solutions pour sortir de la
crise c'est édité chez plon
merci merci à vous
gisèle halimi bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous vous venez d'écrire un
livre qui vous résume totalement ne vous
résignez jamais c'est édité chez plon
et ça résume à la fois ce que vous êtes
et puis en même temps de votre histoire
qui est étroitement liée à l'histoire du
féminisme en france quelques grandes
étapes faire du viol un crime avortement
parité donc on va voir un petit peu avec
vous aujourd'hui où en est le féminisme
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est-ce qui surnage
et qu'est-ce qui reste à construire
sommes nous dans un moment où le
féminisme j'allais dire continue son
son expansion naturelle ou sommes-nous
dans un moment où pas de coup d'arrêt
mais deux choses un peu plus
physiquement comment voyez vous les
choses
vous avez eu raison je crois jean marie
colombani de dire lié au féminisme parce
que ce que j'ai voulu faire dans ce
livre s'est trouvée un peu une ce que je
n'avais jamais fait jusqu'à présent
jusqu'à présent c'est mon quinzième lire
donc j'écris des témoignages des deux
tauliers aux grâces du moment aussi et
armand un roman effectivement un roman
historique la kahéna parce que mon grand
père me disait que c'était notre ancêtre
en tunisie
donc là ce que je n'avais jamais fait
s'essayer je dirais pas théorisé parce
que c'est pas un essai universitaire
mais de trouver la logique le rationnel
je dirais politique est là encore vous
avez dit lié vous avez eu raison parce
que ça n'est pas une logique rationnelle
du féminisme mais deux mots féminisme
qui est un petit peu particulier en ce
sens qu'avant même ne sait pas de
connaître le mot de formuler la chose
rêver de cette libération j'avais le
malheur j'avais une enfance qui va se
ficher j'ai une révolte danse à
désespérer d'enfants qui sont on a tort
de les sous-estimer parce que les
révoltes d'enfants sont souvent tragique
parce qu'on a l'impression comme sais
pas qui parle et moi je me souviens que
c'est à ce moment là je me suis mise à
écrire
donc c'était le ledent de me que ma mère
m'a asséné
ma grand-mère avec lui comme ça ma mère
avec l'ue cops à moi j'ai vécu comme ça
toi tu vivras comme ça comme ça c'était
quoi c'était puisque tu es une fille tu
n'as pas à étudier cette eau vers sont
étudiées toi 15 ans on a voulu me marier
quasiment de force un marchand d'huile
de 35 ans donc et j'ai voulu et moi
j'avais une grande curiosité je lisais
beaucoup je voulais étudier j'ai donc
fait mes études j'ai rien dire presque
contre mes parents parce que bien
entendu ils n'avaient pas les moyens
j'étais dans un milieu socio-économique
tunisie colonisé tout ça pauvre et
superstitieux
j'ai donc décidé il le savait même pas
gelé passer l'examen
le concours des bourses pour l'iss pour
entrer au lycée il faut savoir que le
lycée en tunisie c'était l'équivalent de
l'école privée
ça n'a rien à voir à quel lycée français
et je fais comme ça mon chemin et c'est
à ce moment là chaque fois qu'on disait
ma mère me disait puisque tu es une
fille autour de moi aussi que créer une
révolte
le deal sauvage pourquoi pourquoi le
fait d'être une fille et c'est beaucoup
plus tard c'est pour ça que je parlais
de rationnel politique que j'ai regardé
autour de moi j'étais dans la tunisie ou
le mépris c'est évidemment pour les
femmes et moi en particulier mais
c'était aussi les tunisiens ces arabes
qu'on disait sale menteur qu'il fallait
absolument et des autrement il n'aurait
jamais eu une route etc
et c'est à ce moment là que mam
ma réflexion est devenu plus politique
alors j'ai voulu montrer mon chemin et
en particulier en le comparant à celui
de simone de beauvoir qui totalement l'
inverse qui elle n'a jamais souffert de
rien le gui elle était au contraire fêté
comme une mascotte etc et on s'est
retrouvé dans ce féminisme alors bon je
donne mon âge je commence mon livre 1 27
juillet 2007
j'ai 80 ce jour là et je me dis tout de
même il est temps il est temps de
trouver un lien d'abord j'avais une
recherche d'unité
est ce que tout ce long chemin parcouru
derrière moi est ce qu'elle est une
unité avec le petit chemin il faut bien
dire qu'il me reste devoir c'est
intéressant ce rappel parce que ça nous
il ya des pans entiers de nos sociétés
aujourd'hui de par le monde mais à nos
portes
y compris dans nos pays qui vivent
encore sous ses contraintes
alors que le pays lui même a
formidablement évoluer avec un nouveau
front si j'ose dire qui devrait être
celui de la violence des violences
faites aux femmes safari on l'a vu la
patte héros le premier ministre fait ce
noyau l'an mil à d'entrée de jeu oui
ségolène royal dans sa campagne
présidentielle avait mis en avant l'idée
aussi d'une nécessité de sévir contre
les violences faites aux femmes
donc c'est aujourd'hui le nouveau front
j'ai dû du féminisme en quelque sorte
c'est un des francs mais c'est
intéressant de le signaler parce que
vous verrez d'ailleurs parce que j'ai
une position un peu particulière canton
violence moi je n'accepte pas qu'on se
limite aux compassionnel oui oui on est
battus on vous accueille avec les mots
vous restez après donc moi je dis je lis
absolument la lutte contre les violences
et la nécessité de l'indépendance
économique des femmes
car il est évident qu'une femme battue
maltraité si elle a des enfants et si
elle est dans le ghetto de la dépendance
économique qu'est ce qu'elle peut faire
bien sûr elle s'en va le jour où ça lui
est insupportable bien sûr on
bien sûr on là que bien sûr on s'occupe
des mômes mais un certain moment le mari
cogneur vient est libre en général dit
c'est parce que je t'aime trop qui
veulent à reprendre l a pas tellement
d'autres solutions et elle revient en
revanche prenez une femme qui a un petit
temple au même petit je veux dire même
modeste ouvrier employé ce que vous
voulez vous voyez employés qu'à une
toute petite carte de crédit et bien
cette femme c'est d'abord le soir
d'abord le travail comme chacun sait
socialise chacun dans son travail à une
équipe connaît des gens peut téléphoner
demander de l'aide
autrement avec sa petite carte de crédit
même très petit j insiste elle sait que
c'est pas le trou c'est pas le noir
c'est pas le désespoir de ne pas savoir
où aller que de venir à voir avec ses
enfants donc je pense que tant qu'on
n'aura pas lier les deux choses
on fera de l'assistance et je pense que
les femmes aujourd'hui dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui ont besoin d'autre chose
que l'assistance elles ont besoin
bien sûr de combattre les violences mais
elles ont besoin de se projeter en avant
pour reconstruire aux côtés des hommes à
égalité le futur et elles ne peuvent pas
le faire si elles sont assujetties comme
ça de telle dépendance pour ça j'ai
insiste beaucoup à l'actif un mot sur la
politique parce que vous en parlez aussi
dans ce livre évidemment parce que vous
même vous avez été beaucoup associé
des combats politiques et notamment
évidemment à gauche vous dites un moment
au fond ça reste la politique ça reste
de mettre un peu de couleur femme
dites vous ça c'est la vitrine donc
c'est un peu vous en rester à ce
jugement
parce qu'en même temps on voit que ces
femmes existent fortement la plus la
dernière en date étant rama yade 1 qui a
marqué celui c'est bien dans ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que la politique
d'ailleurs moi j'en ai fait vous disiez
mais même j'en ai fait celle que les
féministes me reprochait d'avoir fait me
condamner pour ça ce que la politique
c'est les mains sales bon moi j'ai été
élu comme député j'ai été en masse à
driss de france donc j'étais dedans
est ce qu'aujourd'hui on a beaucoup
progressé
ouï dire que non ce serait inexact ce
qu'on a progressé autant qu'on aurait dû
le faire avec cette loi pour la parité
en politique pour laquelle j'étais
rapporteur pour le gouvernement et qui a
nous a obligés avait conclu à modifier
la constitution donc un grand
tremblement pour finalement quelques
sièges de plus la vérité le ver est dans
le fruit et dans la loi tant que vous
permettrez à des partis politiques
riche de transgresser la loi en toute
impunité en disant ça ne fait rien je
paye puisque la sanction et finançant
sion ce qu'il aime c'est un moins
preneurs c'est maintenant - prenant dans
lé sud la subvention que les lois les
lois décide d'octroyer aux parties selon
certains paramètres compliqué le don de
député le nombre d'adhérents dont on
comprend un peu moins l'argent mais ça
fait ça fait des attitudes je trouverai
je trouve très arrogante et en même
temps de transgression de la part de
ceux qui font la loi de la loi elle même
ainsi l'ump aux dernières élections à
payer une amende de plus de 5000
une euros le parti socialiste aussi mais
beaucoup moins mais les petits partis
ont été si je puis dire contraint à la
parité parce que d'abord il n'avait pas
d'argent mais il faut reconnaître aussi
qu'idéologique membres la lcr le parti
communiste où ça on était à fond et ont
pratiqué la parité à fond donc
aujourd'hui on se trouve devant une loi
mal fichu la première chose que je
propose moi c'est de changer les
sanctions on peut pas dire si bien
évidemment mais pas financière non je
trouve que dans les lois électorales ya
qu une bonne sanction ou vous est
conforme à la loi
vous êtes candidat oovoo transgressé la
loi et votre candidature est rejetée
donc je sais bien que ça pose un
problème pour le scrutin uninominal à
deux tours mais mais moi j'ai proposé
des solutions il ya des solutions qui
font que on oblige à respecter la loi
sans passer par la sanction financière
on pourrait l'ajouter si vous voulez
vous continuer au fond malgré tout faire
confiance à la politique
écoutez c'est une donnée je crois
incontestable on est en démocratie
alors aujourd'hui les femmes féministes
qui veulent se mettre à part et il
montrait du doigt les assemblées élues
tout ça je crois qu'elles font fausse
route
je crois qu'elles font fausse route
parce qu'elle prenne un chemin parallèle
et commencer les paramètres ne sont
joints ne jamais de notre vraie société
moi je suis pour que les femmes au
contraire s'intègre qu'elle soit dans
les parties qu'elles exigent la parité
au niveau de la décision parce que la
parité comme ça dans la piétaille les
hommes et dans sont assez d'accord mais
qu'elle exige la parité au niveau de la
décision qu'on voit des femmes
secrétaire général de partis de
syndicats et parler mais il n'y a à mon
avis n'y a pas d'autre voie si je le
répète on ne met pas en cause ce qui est
mon cas le de la donnée fondamentale qui
est que nous sommes dans une démocratie
et qu'il faut qu'il faut être dans les
rouages il faut jouer
le jeu démocratique en tout cas gisèle
halimi il ya bien mille autres choses
qu'on pourrait aborder dans ce livre est
riche notamment vous rencontre avec aimé
césaire que tu feras ordinaire qui
m'avait dit jean beige
je rappelle juste son mot quand je les
ai vus demander de nous aider pour le
procès de bobigny fameux procès qui a
permis la loi sur l'avortement et il est
venu me voir et m'a dit non c'est moi
qui viens vous voir
et puis en partant très une après-midi
de poèmes et de lecture à deux il m'a
dit vous allez gagner pilar réfléchit à
travers ses grosses lunettes qui m'a dit
non non nous allons guérir
merci en tout cas gisèle halimi donc je
renvoie votre livre ne vous résignez
jamais vous avez passé 80 ans vous
l'avez dit vous-même 104 adhérents - là
la flamme et est intacte et le la
volonté de continuer à conquérir et est
intacte donc je vous renvoie donc toutes
et tous à ce livre ne vous résignez
jamais gisèle halimi s'était dit et chez
plon merci merci
ce kit bond jour bonjour merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes paléo anthropologue
au collège de france et vous êtes là
parce que nous sommes dans une année
darwin 150e anniversaire de la
publication du livre de darwin sur
l'évolution est donc différente
manifestation intellectuelle existe pour
nous rappeler cet événement majeur et
vous même vous venez de d'éditer aux
éditions du seuil à un petit livre un
petit guide extrêmement précieux darwin
expliquer à nos petits-enfants ou
l'évolution expliquer à nos petits
enfants
donc je voudrais qu avant toute chose
vous nous disiez d'abord ce que c'est
qu'un paléo anthropologues j'aurais pu
dire que parmi vos ouvrages précédents
il y en a un qui s'intitule le singe et
il le frère de l'homme donc ça nous
donne une petite indication mais
quelques mots d'explication puis nous
entrerons dans vif du sujet alors c'est
tout ça à paléo ancien entrepôt ce
l'homme et logo sa connaissance
donc c'est l'étude des origines et de
l'évolution de l'homme alors pendant
longtemps ça a été confondu avec la
préhistoire historique penser c'est la
préhistoire donc les témoignages
culturel les sépare les hommes dits
préhistorique c'est à dire les outils et
l'art pariétal pour les période la plus
récente et la paléoanthropologie c'est
plus l'évolution biologique alors que la
préhistoire c'est l'évolution culturelle
est très longtemps on a vu que l'aspect
évolution c'est à dire les changements
de la lignée humaine
mais dès qu'on touche à l'origine et et
ça nous ramène à darwin là on touche à
une question qui est beaucoup plus
sensible c'est comment émerger ou
l'homme la lignée de l'homme par rapport
justement à nos frères d'évolution aux
cousins les grands sages aux autres
espèces alors quelle est l'actualité de
darwin aujourd'hui parce qu'on voit
surgir essentiellement d'ailleurs je
dois le dire dans la presse anglo
saxonne mais aussi en france également
voilà des débats sur l'évolution quel
est son actualité aujourd'hui
d'une certaine manière nous nous serions
contents les scientifiques
si darwin n'était plus d'actualité je
m'explique c'est le 150e anniversaire de
la publication de l'origine des espèces
ça c'était en novembre 1859
mais c'est aussi en février de cette
année le 2 février le bicentenaire de la
naissance de charles darwin avec un
petit clin d'oeil
parce que ça nous ramène en 1809 je les
dis et là c'est la publication par un
français jean baptiste de la marque delà
de l'évolution non pas au terme dans le
thème actuel mais ce qu'on appelle le
transformisme fait le concepteur de la
théorie de l'évolution c'est à dire du
changement des espèces si c'était dans
l'air du temps c'est jean baptiste de la
marque mais darwin est très important
parce qu'il va apporter le mécanisme
c'est à dire la sélection naturelle et
la sélection sexuelle
alors pourquoi c'est encore d'actualité
et bien c'est qu'on a mis un siècle à
comprendre charles darwin et notamment
s'ils concernent les origines de l'homme
il y a encore beaucoup de difficultés
alors que beaucoup d'avancé avait été
réalisée par lui alors il ya beaucoup de
difficultés des avancées et il ya aussi
des retours en arrière alors on l'avait
vu dans le débat politique lui-même
essentiellement américains je dois dire
à travers ce que l'on a appelé le
créationnisme c'est à dire la tentation
de vouloir imposer dans les écoles une
histoire de l'humanité qui soient
davantage la lecture de la bible
à vrai dire plutôt qu'une lecture
scientifique et donc on a vu alors
peut-être est-ce d'ailleurs un petit peu
relégué à l'arrière-plan parce que
c'était très lié au fond à la présidence
bush la parfaite assez assez
fondamentalisme mais en même temps on
voit que le débat quand même une
certaine garde une certaine actualité et
qu'il peut être transposé en peut-être à
tort allez-vous nous dira d'ailleurs
dans un sorte de face à face science
religion alors que ça n'est pas vraiment
de cela qu'il devrait s'agir alors il
faut distinguer deux choses qui sont
très importantes et qui sont d'ailleurs
confondues à dessein si je peux
m'exprimer par les créationnistes
c'est à dire le débat d'or politique ou
sur les valeurs et ce qui concerne le
débat strictement scientifique
d'un point de vue strictement
scientifique aucun biologiste
et or de la théorie darwinienne ou post
darwinienne pas celui bonjour monsieur
la théorie à elle même évolué bien
évidemment darwin apporte les mécanismes
qu'on avait appelé extérieurs c'est à
dire qu'est ce qui fait que
l'environnement avec toutes ces
caractéristiques va faire que certains
individus vaut laisser une plus grosse
descendance kloet
donc vous voyez bien c'est pas la loi du
plus fort c'est pas le plus apte donc
c'est le fait que certains individus
vont laisser plus d'enfants que d'autres
et donc ça va modifier l'espèce alors ce
que ne connaîtra pas darwin c'est
l'origine de la variation et ça ça sera
l'apport de la génétique
alors ce que disait créationnistes
justement et là on passe le débat social
et politique
l'isda où il n'a pas tout dit mais
attendez aucun scientifique n'a jamais
tout dit c'est comme si l'on reprochait
à newton ne pas avoir trouvé la
relativité ça serait tout le monde rires
eh bien eh bien c'est exactement ce que
l'on fait le seul qui a tout dit ben
c'est pas un scientifique qui s'appelle
dieu donc voila voila la confusion dans
le débarras fusion et donc les
mouvements créationnistes on l'a vu dans
la campagne présidentielle américaine
avec sarah palin qui dit plaidait pour
que l'on enseigne à l'école ce que vous
avez rappelé la science créationnistes
alors qui prend deux aspects ou une
lecture c'est pas la lecture c'est une
lecture fondamentaliste littéraliste du
texte de la genèse avec beaucoup de
confusion d'ailleurs et puis une lecture
plus ce petit qui est le dessein
intelligent voltaire avait bien
distinguer ça c'est à dire le dieu
présent avec sa création donc tout ce
qui se passe autour de nous c'est la
volonté de dieu ou alors dieu a créé le
monde il a laissé évoluer
c'est de là que vient le premier terme
évolué d'ailleurs c'est à dire déroulé
un papyrus cessa l'étymologie et darwin
ne voulait pas de ces termes je peux
vous le dire c'est pour ça qu'il est mal
choisi donc l'idée qu'il y a des seins
ou dérouler une bobine de film voilà
cette image là or justement à la limite
qu'il y ait ce débat moi ça ne trouble
pas du tout mais le problème et ça c'est
pas parce qu'elle pique il dit ce sont
les juges américains des juges croyants
dans un procès de 1982 où là il y avait
dans les états du sud parce
qu'évidemment c'est ce mouvement est
arrivé avec ronald reagan et ensuite
monsieur george deubeuliou bush
ce sont des états du sud qu'ont voulu
apposer en classe de sciences qu'on
enseigne sous prétexte de laïcité
les faux prétextes comme on va le voir à
ton égal la théorie moderne de
l'évolution quand parle de la vie et
aussi la conception donc
fondamentalistes littérale des textes de
la jeunesse est là parmi les plaignants
il y avait les enseignants biologie les
associations laïques laïque ça veut pas
dire les non croyants et laïque
j'ai bien dit laïc et puis bien sûr les
représentants des grandes religions
parce que quel était le danger si vous
favorisez sous prétexte de laisser les
jeunes se faire une opinion par eux même
si son principe est assez sympathique
mais en classe de sciences imposer la
science créationnistes ça veut dire vous
a posé une seule vision du monde qui
dépendent est une religion c'est pas
contre le les terres l'évolution c'est
aussi contre les autres religions et
c'est là vous attentez au principe de
laïcité dans nos démocraties modernes
donc ne tombons pas dans le piège
science religion c'est une concept se
sont qu'une frange des fondamentalistes
évangélistes l'hédoniste américains qui
veulent imposer théocratie et c'est
contre la terre l'évolution pascal est
pas très bien compris ce message un peu
car relativité alors sur la théorie de
l'évolution telle qu'elle est enseignée
en france d'ailleurs il ya volet
recherche que des gens comme vous
d'ailleurs état devra donc vous allez
nous dire très rapidement dans quelle
direction elle s'oriente et aujourd'hui
on peut considérer qu'en france c'est
cette theolia est normalement enseigner
suffisamment enseigner pour parce que le
lien ensuite avec la sphère politique
mais c'est évidemment la façon dont on
va aborder les problèmes de génie
génétique par exemple de vin ou de
médecine qui font appel au génie
génétique avec des débats dont on voit
bien qu'ils ne sont pas simples comment
elles sont pas sain parce que très
souvent ils seront dehors des théories
de l'évolution c'est un vrai problème et
notamment la france
une manière générale on a commémoré un
petit peu cette année darwin et et on
continue mais soyons très clairs il y a
un problème avec la pensée darwinienne
en france que ce soit à gauche ou à
droite d'ailleurs pas pour les mêmes
raisons mais en attendant nous avons
formidablement réagi avec l'éducation
nationale le ministère l'inspection
générale la direction des enseignements
nous avons organisé un colloque qui
s'appelle enseigner l'évolution et on
s'est aperçu que même si c'était quand
même assez présent dans les programmes
que les enseignants n'étaient pas bien
formés c'est à dire que les enseignants
enseignent des faits l'évolution les
fossiles les relations parenté mais qui
ne connaissaient pas bien les mécanismes
sélection naturelle sexuelle et tout ce
qui est dirigé des tic etc
donc nous devons refaire un effort sur
la formation des enseignants et leur
apporter les éléments d'argumentation
lorsque on leur oppose au nom d'une
vérité qui est tout à fait louable mais
un problème de dysfonctionnement dans la
pensée entre le monde des sciences et le
monde des valeurs
donc là on avance très très bien mais
derrière cela
je prends d'un débat c'est celui des ogm
oui par exemple alors voilà ce que les
ogm on soit ya pas vraiment de débat
scientifique c'est avant tout un débat
souvent idéologique à des gens qui
disent ne faut pas toucher aux jeunes
d'aller rétabli lite et d'autres qui
disent si on peut toucher n'y a pas de
problème des deux côtés il se trompe
parce qu'il ya des ogm qui fonctionne
très bien et d'autres c'est une vraie
vache rit pardonnez-moi dette aussi de
penser dames aussi triviale parce que se
prêtait ce qui en a qui fonctionnent
très bien on essaye de faire passer des
choses qui elle d'un produit
scientifiques peuvent être dangereuses
et par exemple l'évolution c'est quoi ce
qu'ont fait les agriculteurs depuis dix
mille ans c'est de sélectionner des
variétés
d'ailleurs charles darwin d'où vient la
sélection naturelle et bien sa place
maurice est inspiré du travail de
sélection artificielle des éleveurs
voilà d'où ça vient le terme et donc on
manipule non pas génétiquement belle
hérédité d'une manière empirique
aujourd'hui scientifiques depuis dix
mille ans cependant la haute touche au
coeur de ce qui va être hérité sur les
manipulations génétiques il ya
différents types et le problème c'est
qu'on a à faire maintenant
non pas à des plantes qui sont
adaptables un environnement qui change
on arrive à des extrêmes qui là ne sont
pas du tout acceptable pour nous et pour
notre santé futurs ou pour une plante
qui va être avec un taux de production
recherchait on va mener plus on va papa
pas faire adapter la plante à
l'environnement on va les minets ce qui
dans l'environnement autour et ça c'est
un déni d'évolution et je peux pas vous
dire que ça va se passer
oui il est très clair que mona de la
réhabiliter plus on aura de grosses
difficultés d'envoyer il va falloir
qu'on reprenne un vrai débat
scientifique là dessus ce qui n'est pas
tout à fait à la hauteur de ce qu'on
pourrait attendre compte tenu des enjeux
et puis pour rappeler l'importance de
l'enseignement au fond de ces théories
mais de leur jeu
d'enseignement parce que c'est en effet
on voit très vite sélection sélection
naturelle loi de la jungle loi du plus
fort etc
voilà je veux dire donc les confusion
s'installe vite il ya une découverte
récente qui montre que un certain nombre
d'embryons été triés en quelque sorte
pour éliminer les causes de cancer
génétique chez tout à fait une voix bien
l'application à l'homme parce qu'on
parlait des ogm aux plantes on voit bien
l'application à l'homme dont vous allez
être au fond tout en étant tout en
regardant le très lointain très
impliqués dans les débats d'aujourd'hui
alors le pin up le clonage moi je ne
trouve pas du tout scandaleux que l'on
fasse attention à ce qu'il n'y ait pas
de prévalence génétique pour un enfant
qui développerait cette maladie par
contre où je suis content c'est le fait
qu'on puisse choisir tous les caractères
d'un enfant auquel cas c'est un déni
d'altérité et l'évolution c'est quoi je
le rappelle c'est très bon c'est la
descendance avec modification c'est
faire de la différence et faire la
différence et pas interdire d'éviter des
drames sur des maladies dont on connaît
les bases génétiques et par contre notre
côté on peut éviter ces maladies mais
néanmoins faire un enfant qui sera dans
sa différence et le respect de
l'altérité et l'évolution fonctionne sur
cette différence
alors pour toutes ces questions et pour
les aborder de façon extrêmement claire
pédagogique simple donc je renvoie votre
ouvrage pascal picq qui est le darwin et
l'évolution expliquer à nos petits
enfants donc c'est édité au seuil
merci de ces explications merci à vous
toutes et vous tous pour celles et ceux
d'entre vous qui souhaitent retrouver
nos invités le rendez vous permanent et
sur publicsenat.fr